if a and b are vectors in space given by
a is i minus 2 j over the square root of
5 and b is 2i plus j plus 3 k over the
square root of 14. then the value of so
we have 2a plus b
dotted with that's a dot product there a
cross b cross a minus 2 b is
and if you and i actually tried this out
a little bit before this video if you
actually just try to first take the
cross product of a and b which you can
do and then try to take the cross
product of that with a minus 2b is going
to be unbelievably hairy unbelievably
computationally intensive and you're
probably going to make a careless
mistake especially when you take the
cross product with a minus 2b it's a
really really really really hairy
problem and general taking cross
products tend to be but even more so
when the when the actual vectors look
like this so the trick of this problem
is to try to do it without actually
having to take cross products and to do
that we're going to use a little trick
called the triple product expansion or
lagrange's formula and i actually just
uploaded a video proving the triple
product expansion for those of y'all who
don't like and i'm one of those
i'm one of the y'all that doesn't like
just random formulas like to see where
it came from but the triple product
expansion it really allows us to rewrite
a let me write over here it allows us to
write a
cross
b
cross c
it allows us to write that and i'm just
speaking in general terms of a b and c
here not these particular a's and b's it
allows you to rewrite that as the first
vector and when i talk about the first
vector in the first cross product i'm
talking about the cross product you
would have to take first in this case it
would be this was cross product on the
right i guess i should call it because
there's other ways that you could take
the cross product first where it's on
the left so you take this the first
vector here so it'll be b scaled by a
dot c
a dot c
let me scroll to the left a little bit
minus the second vector and that's in
that second cross product minus c times
times a dot b so when you have this this
kind of triple product right over here
you're taking the cross product of three
vectors you can simplify it is a
simplification because the dot product
is a much simpler operation to compute
than the cross product so let's see how
we can apply it over here we it looks
like we have a triple product looking
thing here we have the cross product of
two vectors crossed with a third so it's
a slightly different thing than this
over here but what we can do is we can
swap it around so it's the same order so
this over here
this over here in green this is the
exact same thing if i just swap the
order of these two cross products it'll
be the negative so this will be
negative a
ugly parenthesis a
minus 2 b
so i'm putting it first cross
cross
a
cross b so all i did is i rewrote this
green part when you swap the order of
the cross product you put a negative out
front and the reason why i like this and
actually let me just distribute this
negative so this is the same thing if i
multiply negative times this it just
swaps these two terms so it's 2
b
2 b minus a
cross
cross a cross b now the reason why i
like this form is it's exactly the form
that i have up here it's exactly this
form and so i can use lagrange's formula
or the triple product expansion and that
tells us and so i'm just going to focus
on the green part right now we can worry
about this thing out front that we're
going to take the drop product with
later let's see if we can simplify
this green part
so this will be equal to just using the
triple product expansion we're looking
at our second cross product this is our
second cross product over here so it's
analogous to that right over here you
take the first vector in your second
cross product so that's the vector a
and i multiply that i multiply that
times the dot product of this vector and
that vector so it's going to be it's
going to be 2b minus a
2 b
minus a
2b minus a dotted with b
dotted with vector b
and then from that
from that i'm going to subtract the
second vector
i am going to subtract the second vector
let me do that in another color
i'm going to subtract
b
so this is the same b over here maybe i
should color code it this a
this a is that a there and then this b
is this b here so b times the dot
product of
so it's going to be i'll do the magenta
again the dot product of this guy 2b
minus a
dotted with a
dotted with
so the dot product of the other two
vectors now let's see if we can simplify
this
so what we have in parentheses here
so this over here in green
the dot product that that's just you can
the distributive property apply so this
is going to be 2 b
dot dotted with b again or you might
already know that if i take a vector and
i take the dot product with itself
that's the same thing as its magnitude
that's the same thing as the magnitude
of the vector squared so let's just
write that down so this is so 2b dot b
is going to be actually let me just
write it as 2
b
dot b
and then we have minus
minus a dot b
so i just distribute it i didn't
actually use that notation and all of
that's going to be times the vector a
all that is going to be times the vector
a and then we have minus
minus let me pick another color minus
all of this stuff so we have 2
b dot a
so
let's write it let me write it this way
let me just leave the minus b out front
so let me write a
minus
and then i'll put the b over here and so
you have 2 b dot a
that color
so it's 2
b a is the same thing as a dot b so i'll
just write 2
a
dot b
and then minus a dot a
minus
a
dot a so remember we're just working on
this green part right here but since we
already have all of these dot products
of a with themselves and a dot b and b
with themselves and these are pretty
maybe let's just see what happens when
we take the dot if we actually try to
evaluate these and maybe this will
simplify some of our algebra but you
wouldn't have to you could just keep
going with the a's and the b's but maybe
these evaluate to relatively
straightforward numbers since we
actually know what our a's and b's are
so let's try that out
so what is a
dot a going to be equal to well you're
just taking the you're just really
squaring each of each of the components
of a and adding them up so the first
component the i component is 1 over the
square root of 5. so 1 over the square
root of 5 squared is going to be 1
one-fifth
and then negative two over the square
root of five squared is going to be plus
four-fifths
so our intuition was correct when you
take the dot product of a and a it's a
very simple number it is 1. let's do the
same thing with b
if i take b
b
dot b what do i get
so 2 over square root of 14 squared is 4
over 14
and then 1 over the square root of 14
squared is plus 1 over 14 and then 3
over the square root of 14 squared is 9
over 14
plus 9 over 14 and this
once again adds up to one this once
again adds up to one so it looks like
things are simplifying a good bit so
let's just try a dot b
a
a dot b so that's going to be 1 over
square root of 5 times 2 over the square
root of 14 so that's going to be so it's
going to be 2
over the square root of
70 i've multiplied the x terms and then
we're going to have
negative 2 over the square root of 5
times 1 over the square root of 14. so
that's negative 2
over the square root of 70
and then plus 0 this has no k component
so it's going to be 0 times
this whatever the k component is here
but that's still going to be 0. so this
just evaluates all to
zero so that simplifies things a good
bit this green expression right here
simplifies to this is two times let me
just this is two times one which is just
two
minus 0 right a dot b we just figured
out is 0 a dot b is 0. so this is just 2
times a
this is just 2 times a
minus
minus now what is this going to be equal
to 2 a dot b we just figure out a dot b
is 0
and then a dot a we figured out is 1. so
it's minus
negative so this becomes a positive b so
plus
b so all of this mess over here
simplified to
2a
plus
2a plus a b which is the exact same
thing we have over here 2a plus b so
let's actually that we're dotting it
with so let me write it over here so
this whole thing is this over here and
then we have to take the dot product
with 2a plus b again
so we're going to take the dot product
with 2a
plus b again it doesn't matter a dot b
is the same thing as b dot a and they're
the same number so it matters even less
and here the distributive property
applies to the dot product to the vector
dot product let me make sure we remember
this is a dot product that we're taking
this is a
this is a dot let me put in a darker
color this is a dot product so this
whole thing was 2a plus b i'm dotting it
with another 2a plus b
and now this you just use the
distributive property here so you have
2a dot 2a that's going to be
4 times a
dot a
4 times a dot a and then 2 a
dotted with b is going to be plus 2
times a dot b
and then
b dot 2 a is going to be plus 2
b a or a dot b i wanted to switch colors
actually
b i'll do it in the same color as the b
so b dot this is going to be 2
a
dot b
and then b dot b
so plus b
dot b so what is this going to evaluate
to a dot a is one so it's going to be
four
a dot b is zero
and a dot b is zero and then this is one
so we have four plus one four plus one
is equal to five so this whole mess if
you're able to
remember the the triple product
expansion and kind of see the
simplification over here to actually go
it's actually a fairly straightforward
problem this whole mess over here is
five it evaluates to five